Frank Frank I'm not surprised you beat
Joe I think it of Mexican would be able
to pick off a fruit
that's a big fan of One Tree Hill not
the show but the place where his family
used to hang black people
[Applause]
Frank yeah Frank I don't appreciate you
painting me at the races I painted you
that paint bottle keepers I got
appreciate you paying me as the races I
paid you to paint my house right let's
even go he's won do it again you look
like the IT guy to taco truck haha Thank
You Matthew makind again
[Applause]
under owner owner Matt doesn't do drugs
his unsuspecting victims do Frank's mom
is here supporting him tonight and
Franklin was actually so Hispanic that
she's younger than he is
met a lot of likes of food at my work
he's about to get served by a Mexican
[Applause]
electing a legend
to solve legend oh the the price and I
is actually $25,000 which is sad because
even if Frank wins it he'll still have
to use it to pay for the wall okay
[Applause]
women have described Matt as tall
handsome armed and on foot last seen
leaving through their bedroom window
[Applause]
gentlemen let's go for the championship
good God oh great great the Sapphire is
your Hispanic but disappointingly so
you're as Mexican as a whopper eat oh
you think Hispanic people last by going
ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja oh
boy or order mats in really great shape
he looks like he's been training his
whole life to run the Aryan race
[Applause]